[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce set 8
l'hebdo sans nous ferons le tour de
l'actualité de la semaine dans les
yvelines
au sommaire de ce vendredi 8 novembre à
l'occasion des cérémonies de
commémoration du 11-novembre des
collégiens nous présenter les différents
projets réalisés sur la guerre de 14-18
à la rectrice de l'académie de
versailles
vous en découvrirez une partie depuis le
1er novembre les premières mesures de la
réforme de l'assurance chômage sont
entrées en vigueur
nous reviendrons sur ces changements
avec notre invité la député de la 12e
circonscription des yvelines
laurence grand juge incendie du
chapiteau de chanteloup les vignes
journée nationale de lutte contre
harcèlement scolaire et nouvelle étape
pour le projet de fusion des
départements des yvelines et des
hauts-de-seine
nous reviendrons sur ce qui a marqué
l'actualité locale de cette semaine
[Musique]
pour les usagers de la ligne l du
transilien
attention ce week end entre le samedi 9
et le lundi 11 novembre des travaux de
modernisation vont avoir lieu
conséquence aucun train ne circulera
entre paris montparnasse et versailles
chantiers dès 10 heures le samedi et
jusqu'à 16 heures le lundi des lignes de
bus régulières seront renforcés
concernant l' axe de rambouillet pas de
train non plus dans les deux sens les
voyageurs pourront emprunter la ligne
fut prolongée de la verrière à
rambouillet entre mantes-la-jolie et
plaisir grignon mêmes perturbations et
des bustes en substitution
vous pouvez retrouver toutes les
informations sur le site transilien.com
il ya 101 ans
l'armistice était signé mettant fin à la
première guerre mondiale
les commémorations du 11 novembre ont
débuté ce vendredi matin la rectrice de
l'académie de versailles
charline avnet s'est rendu au collège
léon blum avait à villepreux pendant
trois ans d'établissement sous l'égide
de trois de ses professeurs a mené un
projet pour le centenaire de la grande
guerre un spectacle mêlant saynètes
lecture de textes en français et
allemands et chante the sound à
d'anciens élèves sont venus en restituer
quelques extraits de ce travail propos
recueillis par grégory canada on pensait
au départ faire quelque chose là c'est
intime c'est venu en fait de la
proposition des élèves même si désolée
mais au manque d'ambition
c'est quelque chose qui nous tient à
coeur on a envie de faire les choses en
plus grand
ça va beaucoup me servir je pense parce
que ça m'a permis vraiment de vins 2010
parce que j'ai vraiment changé en fait
entre 4e 3e jeu vraiment évolué et
évoluent et donc vous
c'était france c'est vraiment une super
expérience de façon c'est un très beau
moment à un moment de mémoire est aussi
un moment de joie et d'engagement de
de l'ensemble des lycéens collégiens et
plus jeunes qui peuvent participer à ce
travail et à la fin de cette émission
pourrait retrouver un extrait de leur
travail
d'autres élèves engagés au collège la
clé 100 pierre à elancourt
il accueillait l'opération 1000
chercheurs dans les collèges du généthon
points ou de cours sur la génétique pour
un cours sur la génétique la recherche
biomédicale et le quotidien d'un
chercheur une sensibilisation pour les
élèves de 3e au métier de la science et
aux enjeux des nouvelles thérapies mais
aussi au téléthon
maty de 2010 aujourd'hui dans la classe
des 3e 2 du collège la clé saint-pierre
ses cours de sciences avec le généthon
au programme court de génétique et
présentation du laboratoire et des
chercheurs de la fmt les ponts j'appris
bad et je suis tout seul sur l'adn et
sur les cellules
sur les cellules souches aussi et
bah du coup elle son métier aux
représentants qu on en train de
travailler sur la d elle et du coup bah
enfin là c'était un peu plus élaboré ce
qui est logique et normal et du coup on
a appris plus parce qu'on n'était pas
allés aussi loin leurs professeurs du
jour jérôme denard ingénieur de
recherche qui explique ses missions ses
expérimentations et son programme de
recherche sur les patients atteint
d'amyotrophie spinale une maladie
neuromusculaire
ça a été très interactifs ils ont posé
beaucoup de questions des questions
pertinentes les questions auxquelles
j'avais même pas pensé donc il y avait
certains élèves qui qui avait bien
compris le mécanisme de
de thérapie génique non c'était très
très intéressant dans le cursus d'un
élève de 3e en sciences et vie de la
terre
on retrouve les gènes les chromosomes
ainsi que les cellules reproductrices
imparfait parallèle avec le travail des
chercheurs du généthon tous les ans on a
le téléthon qui intervient au mois de
décembre donc déjà ils sauront de quoi
ça parle
ils seront peut-être plus investi dans
dans le projet qui il aurait présenté
tous les ans la télévision mais pour eux
c'est un peu en dehors de ce qu'on l'en
fait au collège
donc là du coup ils ont un lien entre ce
que l'on fait au collège ce que font les
chercheurs et puis ce qui se passe à la
télévision
l'opération 1000 chercheurs dans les
collèges se terminera fin novembre après
avoir fait le tour des écoles pour
sensibiliser aux métiers de la science
et des enjeux des nouvelles thérapies
[Musique]
le 1er novembre dernier les premières
mesures de la réforme de l'assurance
chômage sont entrées en vigueur parmi
elles un durcissement des conditions
d'accès à l'assurance chômage
il faut avoir travaillé six des 24
derniers mois pour ouvrir des droits
alors que jusqu'à présent il en fallait
quatre sur les 28 derniers mois un mois
de travail ne suffit plus pour recharger
ses droits désormais le délai est
allongée à six mois pour les hauts
salaires ceux à plus de 4500 euros brut
par mois dégressivité de la location de
30% au bout de six mois non travaillées
enfin l'assurance chômage et élargi aux
démissionnaires et indépendant mais sous
de strictes conditions notamment cinq
ans d'ancienneté dans l'entreprise et
présentation d'un projet de reconversion
en commission florence grand juge vous
êtes avec nous bonjour bonjour vous êtes
député de la 2e circonscription des
yvelines et l'assurance-chômage vous
connaissez bien car vous avez travaillé
plus de trente ans pour pôle emploi
tout d'abord pourquoi cette réforme
alors il faut savoir que c'est pas la
première fois qu'on réforme l'assurance
chômage l'assurance chômage a toujours
été en adéquation avec le contexte
économique alors l'assurance chômage
l'objectif c'est d'assurer un revenu de
remplacement
c'est une comment dire une indemnisation
qui est versé aux demandeurs d'emploi
mais il est important qu'on soit en
adéquation avec le contexte économique
avec la situation donc du marché de
l'emploi
et si en 60 ans d'assurance chômage il
ya eu plus d'une dizaine de raifort nous
sommes aujourd'hui en situation où le
taux de chômage est un des plus bas
depuis 10 ans lorsqu'on regarde un
certain nombre d'éléments et bien
lorsque l'on voit là la reprise d'emploi
comme l'a signalé un muriel pénicaud et
lorsque l'on voit aujourd'hui que l'on
peut gagner plus
en ne travaillant pas qu'en travaillant
eh bien on se dit que c'est le moment ou
jamais de se questionner de s'interroger
et de réformer cette assurance de façon
à avoir une politique de l'emploi une
politique incitative et c'est tout à
fait ce sur quoi nous avons travaillé et
ce sont donc les mesures qui ont été
adoptées et avec une mise en place au
1er novembre dans un premier temps
puisqu'ils auront ensuite des mesures
qui seront mises en place en demies
non mais on va revenir dessus cette
réforme des halles est contestée
notamment par les associations de
défense des personnes en recherche
d'emploi
lundi grégory canal et recevait
elisabeth aigueperse bénévole au sein
des solidarités nouvelles face au
chômage ou en écouter un extrait sec on
fait porter aujourd'hui le le poids de
l'assurance chômage sur les chercheurs
d'emploi le problème c'est que ça
précarisent les plus précaires cirque
avant on parle entre autres des
personnes qui ont des kings des clients
qui enchaîne les cdd
il avait il suffisait d'avoir un mois de
travail pendant la période pour pouvoir
recharger des droits aujourd'hui il faut
avoir travaillé six mois sur la période
et vous savez des personnes c'est pas
qu'elles ne veulent pas travailler moi
j'en connais pas qui ne veulent pas
travailler et ce sont des personnes qui
ont des difficultés à travailler pour
des tonnes de raisons vous avez la
fracture numérique aujourd'hui on
cherche du travail uniquement par
internet et des personnes qui savent pas
bien faire ça donc c'est compliqué de
trouver des contrats
il ya des personnes qui sortent de
l'entreprise qu'ils sont dans une
entreprise depuis dix ou quinze ans elle
se retrouve à faire des cv mais elles
savent plus comment faire un cv donc
toutes ces personnes là se trouve
complètement démunis et on rajoute de la
précarité à la précarité et de l'
angoisse à l'angoissé de se retrouver
sans revenu et l'unedic qui gère
l'assurance chômage chômage en france
prévoit une économie de 4 5 milliards
d'euros d'ici 2022 regard de ce qui
était madame inverse
est-ce que c'est des économies qu'ils
vont peser sur les demandeurs d'emploi
l'objectif n'est absolument pas de faire
des économies et de les faire peser
enfin de faire peser les mesures que
nous prenons sur les demandeurs d'emploi
alors le rechargement de droit c'est
quoi ces deux ça a été mis en place en
en 2014 tous les indicateurs sur le
chômage était dans le rouge tous sans
exception il y avait une montée
importante de la précarité
donc lorsqu'on a mis en place le
rechargement des droits l'objectif était
de permettre à des personnes d'avoir une
indemnisation plus longue lorsqu'elle à
terre elle alternait pardon des périodes
d'emploi et des périodes de chômage
aujourd'hui la situation n'est pas du
tout la même que
2014 on n'a pas le même taux de chômage
du tout et surtout on a une politique de
l'emploi qui est une politique
incitative qui est une politique
systémique est une politique complète
notre objectif c'est de lutter contre le
chômage de lutter contre la précarité
alors en fait comment est ce qu'on dit
sur contre la précarité on a mis en
place les ordonnances travail
on a mis en place la loi choisir son
orientation professionnelle
on a mis en place également un plan
important d'investissements pour les
compétences aujourd'hui il ya de
l'emploi
on a créé un demi million d'emplois sur
les deux dernières années
aujourd'hui il ya des offres de
formation le pic donc ce plan
d'investissement dans les compétences 15
milliards d'euros sont mis en place pour
mettre des formations pour un million de
demandeurs d'emploi peu qualifiés et un
million de jeunes donc lorsque j'entends
qu'il ya des personnes qui sont pas qui
ne sont pas en adéquation avec le marché
du travail
et bien aujourd'hui à pôle emploi il
faut savoir qu'on peut facilement
trouver une offre d'emploi
il ya plus de sept cent mille offres
d'emploi sur le site de pôle emploi il
ya plus de 300 mille offres d'emplois
pour lesquels on n'arrive pas à trouver
des candidats
lorsque vous êtes un conseiller à pôle
emploi et que vous proposer une offre
d'emploi que vous convoquer une
cinquantaine de demandeurs d'emploi et
qui en a qui ne se présente pas le
conseiller pour l'emploi est en
difficulté par rapport également à
l'employeur je peux comprendre qu'on me
dise c'est difficile on ne trouve pas de
travail je pense qu'on fait avec ces
mesures on va également modifier le
comportement du demandeur d'emploi il va
aller plus vite plutôt rencontrer son
conseiller pôle emploi on renforce
également les moyens de pôle emploi
j'ai 30 ans vous le précise y ait 30 ans
dans le service public de l'emploi avant
d'être député
jamais jamais j'ai vu un renfort de 1000
conseillers pôle emploi lorsque le
chômage diminue j'ai toujours vu j'irai
une absence de moyens entre guillemets
par rapport à l'augmentation conséquente
de chômage pas toujours des moyens en
adéquation avec les charges de travail
là on met un peu
as des mesures d'accompagnement des
demandeurs d'emploi l'objectif c'est
vraiment d'inciter retour à l'emploi
bien évidemment il ya une fracture du
numérique je l'entends bien évidemment
il ya des choses que l'on doit mettre en
place et c'est ce que nous allons suivre
également avec je dirais pôle emploi un
renforcement au sein de pôle emploi vous
l'avez dit avec 1000 postes ouverts
notre système de bonus malus au sein des
entreprises au 1er janvier pour lutter
contre l'usagé excessif des séries
griffe
ça fait partie des leviers sur lesquels
on peut peut modifier comportement des
employeurs je pense qu'il faut une
commande dire effectivement on le sait
il ya très peu de demandeurs d'emploi
qui fraudent je crois que les enquêtes
monde qui a que 12 % des demandeurs
d'emploi qui fraudent mais en fait quand
vous recherchez du travail c'est
difficile c'est difficile de se mettre
dans une dynamique d'emploi c'est
difficile également de refaire un cv
c'est difficile d'être en adéquation
exacte avec ce que l'employeur recherche
il ya des personnes qui sont très
éloignées du numérique
le plan d'investissement dans les
compétences l'objectif c'est celui ci
l'objectif c'est de pouvoir proposer aux
demandeurs d'emploi des offres en
adéquation ou avec son parcours ou avec
sa formation et donc les ajustements et
également avec les mesures que nous
prenons nous luttons contre la précarité
puisque nous allons pénaliser les
employeurs avec le système donc de malus
pour ceux qui proposent des emplois
précaires en grand nombre donc ces
mesures de 1er novembre sont qu'un début
on l'a dit d'autres arrivent au 1er
janvier puis en avril 2020 est
totalement un nouveau mode de calcul ou
celui ci l inquiète aussi ce que vous
nous l'expliquer alors on va on va être
très clair on critique aujourd'hui
beaucoup les mesures qui sont prises
mais il faut quand même faire le constat
que la france a le système
d'indemnisation qui est pas remis
les plus avantageux en europe je crois
que sur l'ensemble des pays européens
il n'y a que deux pays qui sont
l'allemagne et la suède qui ont un
système plus strictes que le nôtre
aujourd'hui pour avoir une indemnisation
il faut six mois sur les 24 derniers
mois avec les nouvelles règles mais
c'était la règle qui existait déjà en
avant donc les impacts de la crise
économique de 2008
ensuite en ce en ce qui concerne donc
les mesures que que nous mettons en
place il faut savoir une chose c'est que
on n'accepte pas on n'accepte pas qu'une
personne avec des périodes de chômage et
des périodes d'emploi elle puisse gagner
plus de quelqu'un qui a travaillé un
mois complet donc on va calculer le
montant de l'indemnisation sur les jours
travaillés et on ne va pas on ne va plus
prendre en compte comme on le faisait
les jours non travaillés
ça veut dire que pour être indemnisé
aujourd'hui il va falloir travailler un
jour sur 4 dans les autres pays c'est il
faut travailler un jour sur deux voyez
donc on a un système qui est encore très
généreux
un système qui est très protecteur et
puis un système sur lequel on a réfléchi
c'est une politique d'ensemble
on veut une politique incitative on veut
je dirais mieux accompagner les
demandeurs d'emploi parce qu'être en
situation de recherche d'emploi c'est
extrêmement difficile et en ça vous
recevez rarement quelqu'un qui a été
licencié qui vous dit qu'il est content
d'être licencié en revanche ce que l'on
constate c'est que lorsque le demandeur
d'emploi n'est pas accompagné il va
s'installer dans une situation je dirais
dans un comportement qui sera pas
forcément proactif vous le voyez bien
aujourd'hui j'ai changé encore récemment
choix très souvent mes anciens collègues
de pôle emploi
eh bien ils n'ont jamais autant vu de
monde ces derniers jours que depuis
qu'on a annoncé la réforme de
l'assurance chômage
les gens viennent pour savoir est ce que
aujourd'hui comment ça va se passer pour
moi
mais ne regarde pas me demande pas
d'offres d'emploi or aujourd'hui on met
en place des équipes donc de conseiller
sur l'entreprise et on travaille encore
plus
je tirais fortement l'offre d'emploi
parce qu'on a pléthore d'offres je crois
qu'on a pas loin trois cent mille offres
d'emploi qui ne sont pas pourvus à pôle
emploi on ne peut pas un moment donné
quand l'emploi reprend quand la
situation économique va mieux et muriel
pénicaud l'a très bien dit on voit bien
l'ensemble des indicateurs et on voit
bien que ce sont des emplois qui sont
créés et que ce sont un moment donné des
employeurs aussi qu'on doit satisfaire
on doit être compétitif on va rester
dans l'emploi mais sous une autre
approche mardi soir lors d'une réunion
sur l'engagement au féminin organisé par
votre confrère didier baichère une
trentaine de travailleurs migrants
syndiqués cgt sont venus à sa rencontre
leur objectif interpeller le député sur
leur situation et leur difficulté à
obtenir une régularisation
malgré leurs emplois particulièrement
pour les femmes souvent à temps partiel
et précaires le député a échangé avec
eux et se dit prêt à les recevoir à sa
permanence pour échanger avec les
services de la préfecture et les
représentants des entreprises concernées
florent de congés vous avez travaillé
sur l'intégration des personnes
étrangères à l'assemblée comment
réconcilier des situations parfois
tendues entre demandeurs d'asile
travailleurs et préfectures aux règles
strictes et l'immigration c'est un sujet
très très sensible et c'est un sujet sur
lequel je travaille depuis de nombreux
mois lorsqu'il ya eu la loi donc asile
immigration
j'ai souhaité participer activement aux
travaux
alors l'objectif qu'elle est il
l'objectif c'est que les personnes qui
peuvent être régularisés et bien que ces
personnes là soient accompagnés en fait
on veut une politique d'immigration
responsable on veut mieux intégrer les
personnes qui sont dans les règles et
puis bien les personnes qui n'ont pas la
possibilité d'être régularisés on veut
également qu'elle puisse repartir alors
il ya un groupe de travail qui a été mis
en place nous sommes une cinquantaine de
députés et nous travaillons toutes les
semaines
à raison minimum d'une à deux réunions
ont la semaine dernière on a vu
également edouard philippe avant l'
annonce des mesures pour l'immigration
c'est un sujet qui est délicat c'est un
sujet qui qui est sensible et on peut
pas rester je dirais un sensible à
certaines problématiques
je suis très souvent saisis par des
personnes par rapport à des dossiers de
demande de régularisation et j'étudie
tout et il est vrai que je pense que on
doit
s'attacher à faire mieux tout autre
thématique jeudi c'était la journée
nationale de lutte contre le harcèlement
scolaire l'éducation nationale estime
que cela toucherait 7% des élèves pour
lutter contre ce fléau des jeunes sont
formés 1500 ambassadeur contre le
harcèlement dans les collèges et lycées
de l'académie de versailles
on écoute parce qu'elle voterait
président de l'association de l'enfance
à l'adolescence rang plateau du 7-8
journal autrefois le harcèlement c'était
le harcèlement scolaire c'était dans la
cour dans l'enceinte de l'établissement
scolaire
aujourd'hui avec les réseaux sociaux
c'est en fait un harcèlement non-stop
puisque on le sait internet ne dort
jamais et bien le harcèlement ne
s'arrête jamais et l'enfant on doit
vraiment endurer cette maltraitance de
ces par ses pairs et voilà c'est pour ça
que c'est très dur pour lui et que les
conséquences sont fortes aussi et la
rectrice de l'académie de versailles
annoncé la formation de 25 par an pour
détecter les signaux florence granger
vous faites partie de la commission
éducation affaires culturelles à
l'assemblée nationale vous lutter
notamment contre le décrochage scolaire
la formation c'est la meilleure arme
pour lutter contre le harcèlement
scolaire
alors je crois que il ya plusieurs
façons de lutter contre le harcèlement
scolaire
et surtout il faut travailler sur une
meilleure prévention et une meilleure
détection des victimes
j'ai animé avec laeticia vient qui a été
donc rapporteur sur la loi sur le cyber
harcèlement des séquences de travail et
des réunions à plaisir et apprécie donc
dans des classes ou dans des lycées et
nous avons rencontré des jeunes nous
avons également échangé avec le corps
enseignant et nous avons eu lors de ces
réunions
trois à quatre enfants qui ont craqué et
en fait il n'avait pas été détecté par
le corps enseignant il n'avait pas été
détecté comme ayant été ou comme étant
des victimes de harcèlement ensuite
lorsqu'on a discuté avec laeticia a
vient donc du harcèlement le corps
enseignant nous a précisé qu'il y avait
une problématique un de détection parce
que il n'y avait une problématique de
formation j'ai donc interpellé
jean-michel blanquer qui m'a précisé qu
effectivement c'était une cause
importante donc du quinquennat de mieux
lutter contre le harcèlement est donc de
former donc la formation passe également
formation des enseignants
formation des parents d'élèves et
formation des élèves et là il ya
beaucoup beaucoup à faire parce que
comme c'était précisé dans le reportage
avec les réseaux sociaux avec internet
le harcèlement ça peut être nuitées jour
n'arrive à la fin de cet entretien
merci florence gauche était devenu sur
notre plateau je le rappelle vous êtes
député de la 12e circonscription des
yvelines pierre bédier et patrick
devedjian était auditionné mardi à
l'assemblée nationale
les élus ont défendu le projet de fusion
des départements des yvelines et des
hauts-de-seine un rapprochement souhaité
depuis janvier 2016
les deux présidents ont répondu aux
questions de sept députés des
circonscriptions concernées sur
l'inquiétude dans ces grands
départements quelle place aurait-il au
coeur de la région ile de france
voici quelques-unes de la réponse nous
avons fusionné nos services à plus de
50% nous y avons d'ailleurs fait des
gains de productivité très important et
notre objectif c'est d'atteindre 200
millions d'économies chaque année dans
par le seul fait de cette fusion ça nous
a rendu aussi beaucoup plus efficace
pour nous département des hybrides on
voit bien qu'ils aient un risque de
glissement de richesse et nous voulons
accompagner ce mouvement puisque nous
voyons bien que ça pas naturellement
avec l'obscène et que ce serait trop
long de vous l'expliquer mais nos
populations sont les mêmes nos
entreprises sont les mêmes nuno fluides
sont les mêmes on est les mêmes en
réalité moins de 48 heures après
l'incendié qui a ravagé le chapiteau de
la compagnie des contraires à chanteloup
les vignes
le président du conseil départemental
pierre bédier s'est rendu sur place
lundi midi le département a annoncé
financer l'intégralité de la
reconstruction de ce lieu culturel
les détails de rudy renoncent même s'il
tient encore debout le chapiteau de la
compagnie des contraire n'est pas au
mieux de sa forme
dans la nuit du 2 au 3 novembre ce lieu
culturel situé dans le quartier de la
noé à chanteloup les vignes a été la
cible d'un incendie criminel sous les
yeux des habitants
j'étais apeuré fin ça m'a vraiment
attristé de voir en centre culturel
comme ça brûle et à cause des changes
entre policiers jeu
de cartier inauguré l'an dernier large
propose aux jeunes de s'initier aux arts
du cirque et de la danse
un espace culturel qui accueille
également des spectacles
la perte matérielle se chiffre à plus
d'un million d'euros
il ya tout le matériel qui est
nécessaire au cirque et c'est un
matériel qui coûterait très cher des
installations extrêmement importantes ça
va falloir le chiffre il ya tout le
matériel qui servait aussi à au
spectacle parce que c'était aussi un
lieu de spectacle c'était un lieu d'art
sous toutes les formes ce chapiteau est
géré par l'association la compagnie des
contraires présente depuis près de 30
ans dans la ville le département des
yvelines a décidé de prendre en charge
l'intégralité de la reconstruction de la
structure
lorsque ces cités populaires sont
confrontés à cet océan de connerie j'ai
fini par dire mon mot eh bien nous
serons là aux côtés des maires et quel
qu'il soit on va reconduire le même le
même
voilà donc c'est pas compliqué on a les
plans il suffit de reprendre on refait
un appel d'offres jeu il faudra
d'ailleurs qu'on voit si il est même
possible de faire un appel d'offres
restreint enfin il faut aller vite dans
moins de nom on doit inaugurer ce
bâtiment sa relance et le sourire à sa
relance l'espoir et je pense que dès
lors au moment où la population va
entendre ça aussi les élèves et tous les
enfants qui viennent et c'est l'espoir
est baigné en plus de la reconstruction
du chapiteau le département des yvelines
va allouer une aide exceptionnelle à la
ville de chanteloup les vignes pour
notamment renforcer ses équipes de
sécurité et de médiation le lendemain ce
sont trois ministres qui ont visité les
lieux christophe castaner ministre de
l'intérieur l'intérieur nicole belloubet
ministre de la justice et julien de
normandie ministre auprès du ministre de
la cohésion des territoires
ils ont annoncé que l'état participerait
à la reconstruction chiffré à 800 milles
euros
enfin vendredi matin c'était au tour de
valérie pécresse présidente de la région
ile de france de se rendre à chanteloup
les vignes pour annoncer le financement
intégral du chapiteau provisoire et le
lancement en 2020 d'un fonds de 500
mille euros pour le spectacle vivant
dans les quartiers populaires autres
communes qui a reçu une visite d'état
carrières sous poissy pour une poire son
secrétaire d'état auprès de la ministre
de la transition écologique et solidaire
s'est rendu sur le site de dépôts
sauvages avec ses 38 mille tonnes de
déchets la décharge sauvage de carrières
sous poissy
l'une des plus grandes de france la
lutte contre ce phénomène est l'un des
piliers du projet de loi anti gaspillage
pour une économie circulaire
l'état va verser 800 mille euros
pourrait de nettoyage d'un coût total de
3 millions d'euros
manon par aldo a rencontré brune poisson
nous allons créer un régime spécial de
sanctions sur pour permettre données
pour permettre de donner au maire ceux
qui sont au contact malheureusement et
on l'a vu avec le drame du décès du
maire de signes cet été pour ceux qui
s'opposent eux qui sont en première
ligne et les moyens véritablement de
s'attaquer immédiatement à ceux qui
commettent ces actes illégaux et
insupportable avant de conclure cette
édition tenu à rendre hommage à denis le
monde mieux s'ils s'étaient mondine de
heath était un le 27 octobre dernier à
l'âge de 76 ans est l'un des artistes
dont les oeuvres sont les plus présentes
sur l'agglomération
devant la gare de montigny le bretonneux
devant des groupes scolaires à magny les
hameaux et à voisins le bretonneux
vous avez forcément vu l'une de ses
sculptures la plus connue se trouvait à
sa sortie à la sortie du centre
commercial espace saint quentin
son inauguration remonte à 2000 retour
en images
[Musique]
ça me détend quand je pascual ou moins
je les regarde ses oeuvres je trouve ça
un peu gros un peu trop je sais pas
c'est trop trop figuratif 3
représentatif seuil est un peu la ville
qui est un peu tristounettes quand même
quoi j'ai vu la même chose en belgique
où il y avait des oeuvres comme ça dans
les rues et il ya déjà dix ans et je me
disais pas c'est une bonne idée
les sculptures en terre cuite de noni
mondineu sagement installés rue le nôtre
à montigny font réfléchir dont
contemporain la semaine dernière
l'artiste a inauguré l'ensemble après
trois ans de travail le thème
l'intérieur à l'extérieur
il fallait y penser faire des touches de
lumière des volumes et pour pouvoir
planter des ondes et faire des espaces
verts des arbres des pour animer cette
fête rue quand ils rentrent de leur
travail
le fait de passer la sa des acides
peut-être à oublier le trajet en métro
qui viennent de faire et de dire que je
venais très bien dans mon canapé
les habitants s'y sentent d'ailleurs
tellement bien qu'ils n'ont pas hésité à
s'approprier cette oeuvre d'art devenu
public
les graphiques qui ont fleuri
[Musique]
c'est la fin de cette édition merci de
nous avoir suivis comme promis on se
quitte avec des images en musique des
collégiens de villepreux qui chante la
madelon en commémoration de l'armistice
votre actuel et héros est à retrouver
dès mardi avec le 7-8 journal weekend
sur tv 78
[Musique]
à